three people are now hospitalized after  one person arrested happened after a  fire in the east valley metro police in  las vegas fire and rescue all responding  to a mobile home near mojave and  charleston a bit earlier this evening  police tell us during an argument in one  of the bedrooms someone lit a bed on  fire and a woman was severely burned  investigators still actively trying to  piece together what exactly happened  because of the extent of her injuries  the homicide section has taken over this  investigation at this point whoever lit  the bet on fire would be charged with  attempt murder if she dies as a result  of her injury she would they would be  charged with open murder hearing there  from lieutenant spencer the other two  people at the hospital are being treated  right now for smoke inhalation the fire  also damaged a neighboring home